théâtre d'orléans c'est le défi de
l'année pour les étudiants d'art
dramatique mettre en espace une farce
tragique contemporaine
évidemment la mort rôde ils ont une
semaine pour le réaliser le challenge de
le faire en huit jours bah c'est ça nous
motive en fait du coup on est obligé on
est obligé d'être dedans tout le temps
quoi donc c'est pas plus mal
ne me dérobe un saint lô crimes sexuels
sakho ras bord foutrement c'est un
exercice un peu fou c'est un espèce de
gestes comme ça ultra rapide comme enfin
croquis et esquisses et en même temps ce
qui est passionnant tour pour eux c'est
que on va essayer de les emmener le plus
loin possible en voilà et puis aussi le
fait qu'il travaille dans un vrai
théâtre avec ya sept techniciens qui
travaillent avec nous c'est merveilleux
ça leur apprend la voix aussi savoir
être dans un théâtre qui peut tout à
fait la même chose que quand on est chez
soi même au conservatoire voilà
ressuscite bien le mouton regard
toujours en questionnement et en même
temps c'est la magie de l'instant
donc on interroge toujours le partenaire
le texte tout tout tout tout toujours
être au moins de son il reste deux jours
avant la représentation au théâtre
ivoirien
les répétitions intensives se poursuivre
l'après midi hors scène
merci c'est la main de la mort parmi la
centaine d'élèves inscrits aux cours
d'art dramatique
certains s'en iront intégrer des
compagnies de viendront metteur en scène
ou costumiers d'autres comme camille
aimerait bien marcher sur les traces de
marion cotillard
car la star a fait ses classes au
conservatoire d'orléans à un petit
espoir et on se dit
l'oscar est peut-être possible pour nous
mais j'ai pas la prétention de dire que
je vais faire comme marion cotillard
mais croise les doigts il faut y croire
et travail doit avoir beaucoup de niaque
pour faire ce métier mais ça veut pas
dire qu'ici ça il parle et c'est pas
simple c'est pas simplement avoir du
talent et des heures de vol c'est aussi
parfois quand même avoir un peu de
chance
quoique la chance et depuis quand elle
passe la chance c'est d'être prêt quand
elle passe et pour ses élèves en
dernière année d'arts dramatiques
la chance se consiste déjà avoir acquis
une plus grande connaissance de soi je
sais je fais pas le poids